jean pierre papin l'un des joueurs qui
aura le plus marqué le football français
notamment l'om était à nos moeurs vie
hier soir en effet personne ne manquait
à l'appel
pour participer à la grande fête
célébrée pour les adieux de jpp
c'était au stade vélodrome christian
hänni un stade vélodrome
archi plein pour les adieux de papa jpp
trois lettres qui ont claqué sur tous
les terrains européens hier dans son
fief marseillais l'ancien meilleur
buteur du championnat de france a encore
fait rêver tous les amoureux du ballon
rond et son enthousiasme légendaire et
pour son dernier match il a marqué avec
ses amis les anciens de l'air d'affilée
moser les boli quand j -pp s'en va c'est
une page de l'histoire des années 80 qui
quitte le terrain après ce que je viens
de vivre ici cette quatre heures de
bonheur mais je crois que le bonheur en
fait c'est le football et puis c'est la
vie en général
la recette de cette soirée pour les
enfants malades pour son association
neuf de coeur
hier j pp a quitté ses crampons avec ses
amis ceux de marseille ceux de l'équipe
de france c'était un bel hommage
un hommage pour un joueur de football
humain et généreux